in the snow-capped mountains of the moon
standing high above the rich lands of
the vale
stands the eerie
a storied and impregnable fortress
said to have been built by the legendary
mountain kings in the age of heroes
it is the stronghold of house aaron
one of the oldest noble families in
westeros
their sigil
a soaring falcon over a crescent moon
their words
as high as honor
the aarons are direct descendants of
andal invaders
who sailed across the narrow sea and
came ashore at the fingers
according to legend
sir artist aaron known as the winged
knight
soared through the sky atop a giant
falcon
landing on the peak of the highest
mountain where he defeated the griffin
king in battle
it was the andal's first great victory
over the first men
and so artis was duly rewarded
he was declared king of the mountain and
the veil
and the region was renamed
the veil of aaron
thousands of years later aegon the
conqueror arrived in westeros
house aaron bent the knee to aegon and
his dragons
and were allowed to maintain the control
of the region as lord's paramount of the
veil and wardens of the east
the veil of aaron was the last of the
great kingdoms left
old and proud house aaron did what they
always did in times of strife they shut
the bloody gate sealing off the veil
then the queen regent shara of house
aaron retreated with her son the boy
king ronald into the eerie their
family's impregnable fortress from the
top of their mountain they could look
down on westeros far below its problems
hidden beneath the clouds
but one day queen shara entered the
outer courtyard to find her young son
sitting on the knee of visenya targaryen
and ogling her dragon vega beside her
just as he'd asked for another cake at
dinner little king ronald asked his
mother if he could go flying on the nice
ladies dragon
visenya smiled at shara
so shara imagined did vega
remembering her manners shara asked if
she could have visenya brought some wine
or food she must be tired after such a
long flight
but visenya demurred
bored with his mother's pleasantries
ronald demanded an answer
poor boy
he didn't even understand the question
chara hesitated for a moment then asked
for zenya as a mother if it was safe for
the boy
visenya assured her it was
what choice did shara have
once her son circled the castle she
collected his little ringlet her own
region's coronet and the ancient falcon
crown of mountain and vale which the
aarons had worn for thousands of years
ronald had taken to the sky as a king
but he landed as a lordling
perhaps he considered his ancient rights
a fair trade for a few minutes of flight
as a little boy would
more likely he didn't even notice the
three crowns at visenya's feet
or recognize the swords of his garrison
beside them
over the centuries house aaron remained
loyal to the targaryen dynasty
until lord john aaron joined with houses
baratheon and stark
in rebellion against mad king heiress
no army in the seven kingdoms can match
the pride and chivalry of the knights of
the vale
after all
they were the first true knights in
westeros
the knights of the vale were originally
the knights of andalos
an eastern nation whose people invaded
westeros thousands of years ago
from the sea
the vale seemed to the andals an ideal
new home a wide fertile valley isolated
from the rest of westeros and its
kingdoms by a great mountain range
the first men who held it moreover were
sparse and divided and waded into battle
with bronze axes and armor that couldn't
match handle horses and steel
but what the first men lacked in
weaponry they made up for in ferocity
finally uniting behind king robar royce
the first men smashed the andals in
battle after battle
reclaiming the veil and pushing the
invaders back to the sea from whence
they'd come
learning from the first men the
remaining andals united behind a leader
of their own
not a king or a lord
but a knight who'd been born in the veil
and knew it as well as the first men
sir artis aaron
known as the falcon knight
the armies of the first man and the
andals met beneath the giant's lands to
decide the fate of the veil
so artists had many more mounted knights
than the first men who preferred to
fight on foot
but the first men had seized the high
ground digging trenches in front of
their ranks and lining them with
sharpened stakes smeared with awful and
excrement
six times the andal knights charged and
six times the first men threw them back
but on the seventh a fearsome andal
warrior broke through the ranks of the
first men and the andals rushed through
the gap
if king robert had been wiser he would
have retreated and saved his army for
another day
then again if he'd been wise at all he'd
never have risked his army of foot
soldiers against mounted knights in the
first place
when king robert saw the falcon helm of
sir artists across the field he wagered
that the anvils would break if they lost
their leader and rode hard for the
falcon knight
the singers paint a pretty picture of
the battle
the king in flashing bronze armor
the knight in silvered steel
but the jewel lasted no longer then the
verse of the songs
for king robert had taken a valerian
sword of a dead and a lord
and it sheared through serratus helm
much like a bird's wing through the air
as the falcon knight tumbled to earth
king robot thought he'd won his
desperate gamble
then he heard the trumpets behind him
when he turned
he saw 500 fresh andal knights pouring
down the giant's lance
and the man at its head was also the man
at robar's feet
for sir artists unique in that age or
indeed any age esteemed cunning even
more than martial strength
and had clad one of his knights in his
spare suit of armor
leaving him to die at robert's hand
while sir artist took his best horsemen
up a goat track he knew from childhood
the charge of the andal knights broke
the last great army of the first men who
would never again threaten the new
knights of the vale
some of the defeated would even join
their ranks in the years to come but
many more fled to the mountains choosing
savagery over submission
ever since the knights of the vale
enjoyed an exclusive position in
westeros
they could sally forth from the veil at
will knowing that if battle went against
them they could retreat through the
bloody gate where no army could follow
until the dragons changed the game
when aegon the conqueror landed in
westeros
the queen regent of the vale shut the
bloody gate against the targaryens and
masked the knights of the vale behind it
to lock it but for senior simply flew
her dragon to a balcony of the erie
where the boy king was playing and gave
the boy a ride round the castle
in return for his mother's submission
with the conquest
no more could the knights of the vale
hide behind their mountains nor they
soon discovered did they need to
for thousands of years the other
kingdoms had warred and treated to
balance each other's might whilst the
veil kept to itself
none realized what power the veil could
have until john aaron defied the iron
throne
refusing to surrender ned stark and
robert baratheon to the mad king
the north the riverlands and the
stormlands couldn't have beaten the
other three kingdoms by themselves but
the knights of the vale rode with them
after all the veils isolation does breed
an abundance of honor and pious bleating
which governs their decisions instead of
foresight like a blind man who can only
guess where his horse is taking him
i doubt john aaron had even prepared for
civil war when he raised his banners
instead of handing over his young wards
ned stark and robert baratheon to the
mad king
honor demanded and lord aaron obeyed
he'd have done the same if the boys
hadn't been the lords of two great
houses who could field mighty armies of
their own
but perhaps i give him too little credit
after all
if the war went against them
only lord aaron had a nice impregnable
castle to retreat into and he was wise
enough to take poor lysatully into his
bed to win the riverlands as allies
john aaron won then john aaron died
impregnable
that's how the veil sees itself
shielded from westeros by its mountains
they call the entrance to their land the
bloody gate because during the age of
heroes a dozen armies supposedly smashed
themselves against it except the veil
has been conquered
those vaunted mountains didn't stop the
andals who came by the eastern sea
the people of the vale say that sir
artisaran the andal general flew on the
back of a giant falcon and slew the
griffin king on top of the tallest
mountain
during aegon's conquest one of his
sisters did the same
flying her dragon over the bloody gate
and up to the eerie the aaron stronghold
and the aran boy king yielded the veil
in return for a ride on the beast